Okay, let's get to audience questions this
week.
Uh, this one came in from a few people, but
I'm reading it as submitted.
Ricky.
Ricky says, Hey, David, how likely is it that
Trump will not accept the 2020 election results
if he doesn't win this?
I hate to make this as a mantic thing, but
it really depends on what you mean by not
accept.
Do you mean will Trump just say the results
were bogus or do you mean will Trump actually
activate any means he can to try to stay in
the Oval Office despite the election results
indicating that he has lost the election because
Trump already has not accepted a whole bunch
of stuff that he's wrong about and it's had
no material importance.
Right.
What I mean by that is Trump didn't accept
that hurricane Dorian was not threatening
Alabama.
He used a sharpie to draw a different weather
map, but it doesn't matter that he didn't
accept it.
The hurricane didn't hit Alabama and actual
meteorologists knew that it wasn't going to,
Trump doesn't accept that he didn't have a
record setting crowd at his inauguration back
in January of 2017 but it doesn't really matter.
Trump doesn't accept that he truly just genuinely
lost the popular vote in 2016 to Hillary Clinton.
And he even actually tried to act on that
by starting a voter integrity commission,
but the commission found nothing and was disbanded.
And that's that.
So let's now go back to the question.
Is it likely that Donald Trump is going to
say that the 2020 election was unfair if you
lose it in 2020, I think there's an almost
100% certainty of that.
And there's a few different ways that he might
approach it.
He might say it was voter fraud and really
he won the election.
He might sort of accept the results, but say
that it was because he had the fake news media
and who knows foreign countries, whatever
working against him or China or whatever the
case may be.
Now, will he actually attempt to use force
to retain the presidency between November,
2020 and January of 2021 when the next president
would be inaugurated?
I doubt it.
And if he does attempt it, he will not be
allowed to stay, uh, in the end.
So that is my sense of it.
And I know that there are a lot, interestingly,
this is way more polarizing for our audience
than I thought it would be.
Even among the left.
I mean, I know the right is half bought in
on the idea that the only way Trump could
lose is if there is actually some kind of
fraud.
And I'm not talking to them, but even within
the left, there are people who write to me
and they say, no, David, you, you, you're
not understanding this.
Trump is going to do the things.
Some people on the right set Obama was going
to do.
He will declare martial law in order to justify
staying in the Oval Office, or he will try
to suspend the 2020 election altogether or
whatever.
I just don't see, you know, there was no chance
Barack Obama was going to do that stuff.
And I don't see it, uh, as something that
Donald Trump is going to do.
I think the way that he will fight it is through
a propaganda war.
And that's, I honestly one of the big dangers
of the fake news narrative that Donald Trump
has fomented over the last couple of years
we've talked about how the fake news thing
has successfully sort of caught on in the
sense that now any critical report about Donald
Trump is very easy for Trump as to just say
it's obviously fake.
These are just people trying to take down
Trump.
It can't possibly be true fake news, fake
news.
That's one negative element of Donald Trump's
successfully running this fake news campaign.
The other one though is that, uh, you, you
may be priming these folks to actually accept
these absolutely outrageous narratives in
2020 depending on what your election results
are.
But in the end, I don't see any way that Trump
has even a 1% chance of actually successfully
doing any of those things.
And quite frankly, I think we need to be focused
on winning the election and getting the vote
out.
And I know we've got to fight voter disenfranchisement
and voter suppression and election fraud and
foreign interference.
I know we've got to do that, but if we get
enough people to vote, then it's going to
be much more powerful than anything that they
can do and that's where the focus should be.
Rather than the idea that Trump's going to
suspend the 2020 election, he will say he
didn't lose fair and square.
Uh, but uh, the, the margin of victory should
be and could be so big that in the end it
should not really end up making a difference.